[Music]
all right let's discuss psychology let's
do it yeah I love psychology
I love discussing alright so here we're
gonna be talking about five factors that
lead us to like that influences when
we're making decisions mm-hmm price
is itcool our mood our state of mind
that we're in at that moment that's a
good one
you're history that's also a good one
that's the first one yeah you seem I was
good did you say mine was good either
I'm sorry dude
well she only calls the good ones good
oh but you point at me when I said price
I thought you thought that we connected
oh we did connect because I know you
like the deals okay maybe I don't know
cuz I'm saying cuz those are in this
it's not psychological oh okay
interesting okay so the first one on
this list is they the number write
backwards so number five past decisions
the University of Pennsylvania
researchers have found that our past
judgment influence our decisions so that
we remain constant so people's memories
tend to adjust to make a new experience
consistent with preceding decisions so
this indicates that humans
subconsciously conditioned themselves to
be self consistent in how they remember
the past so the researchers didn't
expand on the consequences of their
findings but it is worth keeping this
bias for past judgments in mind when we
face when we are faced with decisions
okay number four chronic stress so
whether the individual is under chronic
stress could push them toward a high
risk high payoff option because MIT
neurosciences they had discovered this
phenomenon after conducting a study on
mice after exposing the animals to
stress they tended to seek highly
concentrated chocolate milk under
stressful bright light rather than
weaker chocolate milk under dim light
which are you [ __ ] up whose mice have
a shopping problem he imagined a mouse a
girl
[Applause]
going through a lot right there on the
high risk high payoff like what happens
when you're under chronic stress when
yours the high risk the under the light
like it's really bright and hot another
but then they're like oh you're pale cuz
it's a more concentrated but they're
going through the stress because they
know that chocolate milk is late yeah
just like the Hennessy for my stress is
a big witness for both humans and
animals and it affects uh and its
effects on brain and behavior are of
central importance to the understanding
of both normal function and neuro
psychiatric disease impulsivity is
likely to worsen patterns of behavior
that produce the stress in the first
place inducing a vicious cycle oh yeah
so you gotta be careful we're making
decisions all right number three is our
knowledge of a subject so so previous
knowledge of a subject clouds our
decision-making it clouds it yes when
when presented with new information
hmm oh it's too much so here's this is
what they say in situations where people
do not have background knowledge they
become more confident with the new
information and make better decisions so
there's a big difference in how we
interpret the information we are given
and how it affects our decision-making
when it relates to things we already
know versus when it is new or in
unfamiliar setting so this finding is
based on an experiment in which 4,000
participants answer a series of
questions based on topics in which they
had some knowledge and ones that they
had none including fictional scenarios
so participants tended to do better with
the latter scenarios and so this means
that to help people make better
decisions information should be tailored
based on their previous knowledge why do
they were all is so hard I ain't gonna
hold y'all TIFF I feel like I was in
school for this whole thing I was like
man these people are smart you think
liquid Asst I don't know what that means
big words around it because it's like
it's like hey when you're stressed you
might make a bad decision
hey when you when you learn more
information you make better defender
decision yeah yeah subject introduced
their finger into their nose and scraped
out a material from the picking from the
north and then working their way south
subject then reached down and scratch
their buttock no the information one
they're pretty much saying as far as I
understood it that they that you make
better decisions when you only have the
the new information versus when you
think you already know it's a subject
and then you let that previous knowledge
influence your decision what the new
yeah it's like my dad like he's so used
to doing something for like 30 40 years
right and there's like new [ __ ] that
comes out and goes to stories like a
stick with this [ __ ] all [ __ ] one 100%
this is what I know I'll just keep
buying that and don't tell me nothing
new I've stopped learning that's why but
then when you give old people [ __ ] that
doesn't have touchscreen functions but
it looks like a screen you watch old
people trying to [ __ ] touch screen
everything did you see that video of
that old woman at McDonald's it was like
a display of you can use the mobile app
on your phone and shoes like pressing
the sign and she's like say McDonald's
that old people can't go back
she's like that Mouse I was like bright
light chayo milk yeah number two I was
just number one
I felt like it to me take a quiz after
that if I'm nervous
take note okay number two here is the
number of choices which holy should I
totally get it
nickels and now this is paralysis choice
overload so this this happens when
people overthink a decision and they
can't make a choice because of the fact
that there's just too much information
or too many choices so what ends up
happening is that the the amount of
choices you have affects the decisions
that you make 100% yeah if you're
watching something on Netflix with your
entire family mm-hmm and how does the
room decide to stop watching something
if it's not that good cuz right now I
got I got me and the key pretty easy to
suspect we're not we're not in not
feeling it you got a whole committee I
don't my children you're suing my
children want to be part of the family
my son had no idea no care in the world
whatever we're doing he doesn't want any
part of it my other son is like let's
watch this and be my wife for life okay
got it
that's how we're like one person has a
strong feeling about something and it
will just like go if they like my wife's
like okay let's watch borders or like
she has like a genre like it's been a
tough day I want to watch hoarders or
like my strange addiction I need some
trash TV or we come in like hey let's
watch like last night we watched the
transporter 2 because it was like movie
night good night
this sucks so bad oh really but just is
kicking people's asses it the fight
scenes are great they're like okay how
do we write minimal dialogue and then
just get to a fight yeah yeah the fights
are worth it but why else would you
watch that movie for the bed don't know
I know what geo that's a fantastic point
that I didn't think about what we're
really judging the movie did you watch
the first one yes even worse right it's
the same exact [ __ ] it's just driving
cars and kick people's asses yes it's
fast and furious its precedes passing
the fears they like who cares bro this
is cool in it and I'm like yeah it is
cool but nothing that really matters and
stuff but that's how we we get to stuff
somebody has a strong opinion then we
just watch it do you ever back out or
something yeah we backed out a lot of
stuff I feel like because of like this
thing there's like the I know there's
more stuff out there I don't have to
watch this thing that sucks you know I
mean there's just like so much stuff on
Netflix and
no existed or whatever is like
somebody's always talking about a show
we didn't hear about or whatever so you
feel like you have to like constantly
watch them but there's too much man my
problem is I could get interested in
anything and so my dad used to like
channel serve I get so pissed because he
like pause on a channel for like a
minute and I get into it and then you
switch it and then I'm like oh [ __ ] and
then yeah I get sucked into that thing
and then you switch it I'm like I used
to watch the TV guide channel remember
that channel right they have like a
little guy talking even you like watch
what's happening mean you realize you're
just watching that channel like yeah
this is actually pretty good Joe like
just tell me what's about to come on
marathon that just makes me think it's
Sunday I'm shirtless stuck to a leather
couch on a hot day and I'm not moving
and I'm watching Carlton as my mom with
ghost shows yeah she keeps Sunday it's
just like a ghost like it's like all the
ghost shows for like how many go shows
are really true ghost stories haunted
ghost story ghost attack we're kids
reincarnating and stuff I'll be messing
with that Ghost stuff so I'm really
aware methods don't serve it to me or
HGTV my favorite Channel HGTV he never
does no projects though he just watches
people know that's TV and the Food
Network oh yeah I love who network
that's a good argument when people are
like we have to censor what our kids are
watching cuz they're gonna like pick up
all these patterns it's like bro I grew
up watching the food child or [ __ ]
cook I tell you she was huffing she
watch people flip perhaps you like
that's how you do it I'm gonna drop it
today the whole thing it's next time
I'll bring it up you guys can make fun
of it cuz it's funny oh no my kids are
gonna do call of duty and realize but
but they watch DIY should never do it
alright last one here on the list is
remember we're talking about factors
that affect your decision-making the
number one on this list is hell hungry
you are oh do not make decisions when
you're hungry because psychologists have
found that hunger significantly alters
people's decision-making making them
impatient and more likely to settle for
a small reward that arrives sooner than
a larger one plummets at a later date
that's what hydratation that's like
don't go to the grocery store if you
knew all the time I know like you need a
piece in low blows your store no no even
for me like the hunger and the pee
fiends the same way we're like if I'm
gonna buy something online and I'm like
stuck between two or three things and
I'm a question I gotta pee instead of
buying I'm still pee first
cuz I'm usually gonna make a bad
decision I do that to somebody I come
back and like really look at what that
was like I'm so [ __ ] weird you guys
know this already but I punish myself um
meaning like if I have to go pee and I'm
doing a task I will not let myself go
pee until that task is done that's all
my wife this I don't know why I didn't I
hope you my pants I could hold it in
like four hours my feels like I don't
have to pee at all like not even there's
nothing going on and then also no Mike I
gotta go right now I don't think I'm
gonna make it most times I like the
bathroom could be like right there down
there scared hold it at all I pee a lot
at night - I got you wake up in the know
that two or three times in the other
night it is the three key I don't know
but I'd be thirsty I'm just so thirsty
man especially right before bed I just
like this big water bottle is like gonna
have to pee in like two four six it
sucks okay hey PA
it's the worst man cuz like when you're
laying down you have to pee
you know you can't go all the way to
sleep if you have pee at the best is
splashed the most yeah sometimes you
don't want turn the lights on it's a
whole thing yeah if I'm about to go to
bed and I feel like I'm just like a
little bit like a twinkle of pee yeah
exactly
just a tiny bit I have to go yeah I am
so [ __ ] terrified of having one of
those dreams where you're going to the
restroom in your dream
and you accidentally pee in real life I
haven't had one since like my like I
think I was like 20 the last time I did
I have those dreams all the time but I
don't actually pee in my dream I'm
relieving myself but then I still have
to pee and in my in my dream I'm like
wait but I just went but I still feel
like I have to pee I've touched myself
well I checked myself in the middle of
the night like I'd know I for sure P
because in a dream you're paying for
like an hour you know that means my
conception of pee and then you get up
you're like oh thank you Jesus and then
you pee it feels so good Pete feels good
sometimes shivers I had a dream I was
peeing on messy hookers and then and
then when I woke up thankfully I didn't
pee the bed
[Music]
you